Jeff Kitchen, Dramatist / Author / Founder
/ Consultant: The URL is Sabian symbols.com
forward slash the dash
Oracle and it's s-a-b-i-a-n.
Film Courage: What's next?
Jeff: I’m really liking how
dynamic this story is and how
it's loaded with possibility in a really fun way.
It made me curious, there's this thing that's
similar to like a tarot reading that's called the
Sabian Oracle that works with the Sabian symbols.
You get like a little mini reading from it.
It was an astrologer sat down in the 1920’s with
a psychic and held up 360 cards one degrees two
degrees and she saw an image for each one and
he recorded them. You like focus on a question
trigger. It's the same thing in Tarot, you
think about a question and then pick some cards
and you get some kind of reading from it. This
is not something I'm into. I do it a few times a
year out of curiosity. Sometimes it's not worth
much, sometimes it's really interesting and so
just for a story that's this kind of partially
formed with a lot of interesting potential
I thought it would be just curious to see
what what comes up for it wonderful so
so really I just want to like focus for
a minute on what I'm actually questioning
this would be the intention of your story the
protagonist's journey it's more like a question
and like so as I'm focusing I'm finding myself
in the position of the android like I'm being
the robot and kind of like looking at the
world that now confronts me probably the Sun
and in my confusion about
the contradictory elements
it's almost like what is this I'm not sure
if I'm not sure if I'm vocalizing it right
but almost like what is this story about
and I'm seeing it from the point
of view of this like confused robot
the site is what is the URL of the
website okay so here's what it said
a nature spirit dancing in
the midst of a waterfall
that's what this psychic that's the image
she saw a nature spirit dancing in the midst
of the waterfall and then there's like
an interpretation so I'm just the image
doesn't do a lot for me right away but I'm
curious the paragraph below it what that says
it says this symbol shows skipping lightly
over the surface of Life dancing and playing
you may feel emotionally light and almost
mischievous the worries of life and the
deeper parts of your feelings are ignored as you
effortlessly flit over the surface of any troubles
whilst this is essentially a beautiful symbol of
Joy Harmony and a lightness of being there may be
an element of feeling cut off from your body or
reality this can lead to a sense of alienation or
difficulty in knowing where to land or evading
Problems by ignoring them or Rising above them
effervescent Spirits dancing in a
Carefree manner water and fun Peter
Pan attitudes celebrations of the natural world
waterfalls Mist nymphs fairies subtle Energies
irresponsibility the avoidance of
real situations not taking anything
seriously escapism moving or flying around
perceptions of light fear of dark places naive
so that's interesting in terms of this
robot and and what's interesting about it is
we talked about the sun corrupting the operating
system of this kind of like Super Robot for lack
of a better word and we talked about like seeing
Spock like on catnip where he's like rolling
around on the floor laughing and like this reminds
me of that and it kind of amplifies that aspect
of this story in an interesting way in other
words it's just a what if it's it's kind of
like the 36 dramatic situations like I'm looking
at ambition and it triggers a lot of possibilities
as I'm looking at this like the image itself a
nature spirit dancing in the midst of a waterfall
I was like I don't know what that means didn't
really like grab me but the explanation is great
feeling emotionally light and almost
mischievous that's an interesting word
the worries of life and deeper parts of your
feelings are ignored as you effortlessly flit
over the surface of any troubles it's almost like
this the sun has like gotten them high on crack or
something like he's like this robot that's usually
like that's not logical we shouldn't do that like
really organized efficient on top of things all
of a sudden like I want to look at the little
birdie and can we wrestle it's like just kind of
deliberately like had a wire snipped by the new
owner to make it more malleable and yet it's also
plays into well it talks about the element it says
well this is essentially a beautiful symbol
of Joy Harmony and a lightness of being there
may be an element of feeling cut off from your
body or reality which is interesting for a robot
cut off from reality is one thing
cut off from your body is another
but it really is like a personality change
and yet it seems great like you're happier
you don't care about logic anymore
like Spock wants to play the guitar
instead of do Quantum calculations or something
Um this can lead to a sense of alienation
or difficulty in knowing where to land
see that's the thing of like
I used to be super clear about ethics and how to
navigate certain types of things and now I'm like
it reminds me of the what was it um
the the killer robot movie from years ago RoboCop
and at one point toward the end of the movie The
RoboCop is trying to go down a set of stairs but
it can't do stairs the way and it comes up to
the and it's like toes are like trying to like
it's trying to like how do you do this like it
and it fell down the stairs well the idea of like
trying to difficulty in knowing where to land like
how do I navigate this terrain it's foreign to
me now that I feel more giddy or like the robot's
gonna think this has been a great upgrade in his
system but it really it's like snipped a wire
and made him happier and looser which is desirable
from his point of view because he wants to be
human it's like data learning how to laugh and
yet it's also like this is kind of scary I feel
out of sorts I don't know what's real effervescent
Spirits dancing and carefree manner water and fun
remember we kept talking about the beach and
being a good Surfer Peter Pan attitudes it's
it's interesting it's like the sun could really
have sort of gotten him high what I mean and
it's he's like this is fun I can surf the girls
like me it's like I ate a hot dog today it's like
it's tempting
and it's not just tempting
it's gratifying and it's also
discombobulating if that's the
right word like the lack of judgment
but it's liberating I mean that's it and it see
how it fits in with the Dilemma like I can't
let go of this because it's creating me it's the
best thing that ever happened to me and I can't
keep doing this because I don't trust it I feel
manipulated part of me is like screaming that this
is all wrong and the art other part of me is like
let's smoke more crack this is great so it's like
but I know that smoking the crack is bad but
I need I'm starving for that human capacity
and then the negative aspect of it
is irresponsible irresponsibility
avoidance of real situations not taking
anything seriously escapism naivete
so that was just like a fun venture but it really
suggested a highly specific way that the
sun could corrupt the operating system
and it's a reward system it's experiencing
some of the joys of being human
in a way that's irresistible and yet also
and it's very much wish granting
here's your wish of becoming a real boy
and be careful if yeah you get all your wishes
but things go wrong too in this type of story
but that was that was an interest ing what if
did you type in a question no okay I just
thought about it you just and then just
hit this button and then it brings this up
but I was focused you could see me focus
for a minute like I'm the robot I'm like what
how do I deal with this and like what's this
story about of this robot trying to figure out
how to deal with this and that just popped up
and I probably won't even think about this for
another six months like it's not
part of my normal thing at all.